okay if the vikings win this week will
you wear a kirk cousin's jersey on the
sh on the show next week or on this
podcast
yes i will okay there we got it we got
it on tape and let's go vikings all
right i guarantee you i guarantee you if
the vikings win i will wear a kirk
cousin's jersey next thursday guaranteed
i love it cousins back to pass straight
in the pocket jump over the middle route
off five touchdowns
kirk cousins has thrown four touchdown
passes two consecutive weeks and it's
34-24
fight games
and the vikings would win the game 42 to
30. let me tell you the most impressive
moment of the day for me and let me set
it up for you chris i was talking about
this earlier before i got here yeah
when the vikings were up
it was 35-24 yeah
and the
lions had they had time to try to tie
the game or win the game they had time
with matthew stafford they can move the
ball as the lions were moving down the
field for what would ultimately be a
touchdown you could see kirk cousins on
the sideline with his hat on and he was
pacing he knew i got to stay in this
moment i got to stay in the zone we
can't have to make a play out and do
stuff right now i'm gonna have to make a
play at some point
and that's second and sixth play after
the lions score the touchdown they go
for two they don't get it it makes it 35
to 30. and so if the lions get the ball
back they can just win it in overtime
field goal isn't going to force overtime
they got to go for the win yeah kirk
cousins and they got dalvin cook right
first down they run it okay second down
they're gonna run it everybody thinks
they're gonna run it play action
and i thought okay it's gonna be like a
little seven yard pass get the first
down keep the clock moving he unleashes
the long ball to stefan diggs connects
in stride diggs didn't score yeah um but
i think as the ball was in the air i
heard it go suck it florio the the ball
wisely covers up i don't know if he saw
a video image up there but uh he covers
up and then the vikings scored the
touchdown from there because look
i i i've seen this movie enough times to
know that they'd still find a way to
settle for a field goal and the lions
drive down and they get the touchdown
the two-pointer we go to overtime yes
they scored the touchdown to finish that
drive and something clicked something
snapped something popped and kirk
cousins in the aftermath of the chicago
bears game and their criticism was so
intense and guys like me were saying how
do they get out from under this contract
they're stuck with this guy through the
2020 season what do they do do they
trade him to someone and give a first
round pick like the texans did when they
gave a second round of the browns to
take brock osweiler off the books what
do they do how do they get out of this
and since then it's been great
performance against the giants great
performance against the eagles and the
one that really has convinced me is the
great performance against the lions
because that's the one that they
ordinarily usually see the slip up yes i
it was a big question certainly i get it
and it is i mean he's playing phenomenal
the vikings are playing phenomenal you
know
there may be you know they're they're in
the third segment of the show because
they're not the green bay packers or
anything like that but it's very close i
mean there's a lot of similarities there
to the way they're playing i mean run
the ball first play action passes when i
watch
minnesota on film every week i'm just
i'm not only amazed by their run game
and the diversity of that but they have
continued to grow the offense around
kirk cousins and adam thielen and diggs
and his play action passes and they run
more bootlegs than anybody you'll see
you know fake the ball to the right to
dalvin cook there comes kirk cousins
booting out to the left side and he's
got people coming across the field it
doesn't have to be a complicated formula
when you run the ball the way they do
but he is on fire right now and it's not
like he's throw it's not like you're
looking up and going whoa he's seven for
eight and he's throwing a bunch of
screen passes and short passes like you
said these are aggressive downfield
throws where he's got to put it on the
money and he's been doing that he made
history yesterday it's a very specific
history but it's still history yeah the
first quarterback in league history to
throw for 300 yards or more and have a
130 plus passer rating in three straight
games wow and and you think about all
the great quarterbacks who have played
and if we to come in here and i'd have
given you that stat right we'd have gone
way down the list before we got to kirk
definitely we'd have been peyton manning
tom brady patrick mahomes dan marino
nope kirk cousins first one to ever do
it and it's amazing and dalvin cook had
another 142 yards rushing he currently
leads the nfl in part because christian
mccaffrey was off this week but still
yeah he leads the league diggs had 142
yards they lost adam thielen on the
first touchdown drive of the game and
they just kept going
35 points without him yeah no i know
that was uh something i worried about
because it is a little bit of a just a
two-headed monster at the wide receiver
position and here's a bootleg to the
left and coming across the field great
throw and of course that's thinks that
thielen got hurt hopefully he'll be okay
but he thinks he'll play thursday night
fighting it's week to week yeah and and
look you don't need him thursday night
against washington you need to save him
for kansas city or dallas that's what's
looming don't play them thursday night
it really is amazing to me how they're
making it work and you see that bootleg
to the left and you wonder when defenses
are going to account for that right
adjust to that but i don't think they
can because they're keyed on the run
exactly they can't react put them in a
tough spot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports